[Music]
welcome to Legacy land I'm living in a
legacy land modernizing whatever I can
while the past is always
excited about this I brought an electric
sousaphone did you forget yours or she
might be asking all right how do these
help me out in Legacy land automate
everything and if necessary use code
there's actually another really cool
feature that came out it's called CPU
boost
everyone say
Google itself is actually turning 25
years old at this little startup called
Google it was really hard to beat the
bandwidth of a Honda full of hard drives
we have to simplify so you know we got
to talk about secure and got to talk
about security there was a zero day
vulnerability in a little open source
Java Library called blog for Jay seems
ideal
every fixes that are 10 years old but
still we're shipping shipping something
here in Legacy land but let's be real
your sling in containers your tweaking
release pipelines this is a minor
security incident that happened
yesterday it's actually generated by
duet AI here we go we've actually got an
app yay we just shipped a web and mobile
app and we mostly use natural language
right to describe it now we're ready to
see how the world of data is changing a
testers I like to think of those kind of
like cryptographic Pokemon and I'm going
to collect those along the way this
spring my team wrapped up one of the
biggest data migrations in the history
of the planet here's where it gets fun I
mean I can bring in data from Apache
Iceberg now if I want to we always want
to make sure that we can build
experiences that are more personalized
for our customers
I'm living in a legacy land everybody
take a minute to appreciate what just
happened
foreign